game one of the eastern conference
finals his block was the signature
moment
of an overtime win in game two his 15
point third quarter helped the heat
erase a 15 point deficit
and bam the heat took a two nothing lead
over the celtics
game three saturday rebecca harlow with
a preview
there was an eerily similar feel between
game one and game two of the eastern
conference finals between
boston and miami and that the celtics
blew a second half double-digit lead in
both games
kemba walker saying that miami simply
wanted it more
they played harder after the game there
was an emotional outburst amongst
players in boston's locker room
it's ups and downs with families all the
time but
you know we embrace each other who we
are
who marcus is i love him for plays with
passion
he's full of fire we need him to
continue to have that
what happens in the locker room we got
to stay in the locker room uh
she's not supposed to come out here and
talk about you know what we talk about
as a team after a win or a loss
i mean we're frustrated but uh i mean
that's team sports she's not supposed to
be happy we down here too
team sources told me on friday that the
celtics held a meeting and any drama
that took place has been squashed
boston's primary concern heading into
game three
is correcting the third quarter letdown
in which they were outscored
37 to 17. i figured some things out
two times now we've had a couple
double-digit leads and
you know we let go the ropes so we gotta
figure out you know how that keeps
happening
and just be prepared to win the next one
we just never gave up
we started guarding the way that we're
capable of rebounding the basketball
always helps to make shots don't get me
wrong but i think all in all
we didn't give up there is no doubt that
we haven't seen
the most connected version of the
celtics in this series according to the
team
but what's also becoming clear the
heat's depth and versatility is hard to
overcome
with the heat winning 10 of their last
11 games here in the playoffs
all right thank you rebecca most
impressive number to me
so far out of that series 59 assists on
80 field goals for the heat that's
74 percent of their buckets they're
assisting on
charles why is it two nothing well
uh turnovers number one uh boston half
court office in game two especially 20
20 turnovers or 26 points but i'm going
back to game one when they had to lead
and they ran two of the worst plays i've
ever seen they gave the ball to kimball
walk at the top of the key he dribbled
for 22 seconds
tried to take van by the bottle you one
and one and got it blocked the next play
down they still got the lead
they get the ball to jason tatum 30 feet
from the basket he dribbles shot the
clock down and shoots a step back
30-footer
that's not good offense take the ball to
the bathroom you see when the heat
needed a basket
jimmy butler took the ball to the basket
and got a three-point plate
but the bottom line is jason tatum did
try to take the ball to the basket
he did but before then before they came
back listen
to me uh our job is to be honest on this
show
kimmel walker's got to play better plane
is simper
he is a vet he's been an all-star
they gave him hundreds of millions of
dollars to come to boston
to take them to the next level he has
not played well
it's time for him to step up one of the
responsibilities
of being a star you cannot hide you
cannot disappear
i was actually and i love what jason
tatum said
i would kill a guy if he went to the
press and start telling
what happened in the locker room i mean
it and i have
you can go back and check my date i have
physically whipped the hell out of guys
i say yo man
you don't tell people you don't tell
them what go on in the locker room
it's not their business we don't we
don't run to the press like
little like little punks because he's
right families have fused but he don't
talk about it to the press apparently it
was loud enough for reporters to hear it
yeah it was but i'm saying i just like
what jason tatum said hey
y'all don't ask me about what happened
in the locker room that's the team thing
if they yeah if they overhear it that's
fine but
but you come out and say right away hey
guys we had we having some family stuff
but we ain't going to talk about it to
you guys but all of you with all of you
as players
know that that happens what's that of
course stuff in the locker room
yes but i mean if you overhear it
through a closed door
like all right like but if you come out
and say it
because my my thing is always the guy
that you have the problem with the issue
with is six feet away from you
so all you have to do is go to the next
locker like if i ever had a problem
you know one thing that my teammates
would always say is
can he always came to me like i'm not
going to go and talk to you know eddie
sefco
and all those guys and that with houston
i'm going to go to vernon maxwell and go
to mario early i'm
like oh mario was one of the guys would
say i need the baltimore
so instead of saying oh i got guys on my
team i'm like mario
if i got a cloud on the wing i got you
on the wing cloud is the first option
but i'm going to let you get this and
i'm going to let you know why
but i'm not going to say it in locker
right i mean out in the media that
doesn't make any
cause it doesn't help because i need to
get you involved in it well i think one
issue though is
who in the media is reporting and
reporting this
and who off that team said this to you
because i actually had a very similar
situation happen with me
uh with steve kerr in 2016 i want to say
i believe it is
where we had an argument in the locker
room in okc
and yet you know there's a reporter
standing in the hallway and hear it and
then reports
on it why are you reporting something
that's not being reported to you
you're standing outside that's almost
eavesdropping no one's talking to you
you're standing outside of a locker room
and then you're reporting what you hear
at the door
that's ridiculous your job is to report
well then
that wasn't that person reporting that
there were that
two guys hadn't had had words and well
why does that matter
locker room is a sacred place it's a
safe place for players if players
that's that's a closed door we didn't
argue in front of you on the court
that's what you report you don't go
report what's happening behind a closed
door in our locker room because
the walls may not be thick enough or the
door isn't thick enough and you can hear
you report what's being told to you or
what you see on the floor your report is
something you can't even see none of the
questions
who said what you think the question
would be like
draymond i overheard something can you
elaborate on what was going on
and then he's reporting on that exactly
but to say i
heard this through a wall
i would have to agree with that's not
reporting that's eavesdropping you can't
put a name to a face how can you report
that
you have really have no you know like
sometimes you hear yelling screaming you
have no idea
what they're yelling and screaming about
yeah and that's and that's when you ask
that's why you say hey look we're
standing out here
and it sounded loud in here it sounded
like without question guys we're going
at each other
but what jason tatum say that's that's
the perfect answer to me
we don't bring our locker room stuff out
to the public right no i do have
something to say about chuck
let it go you know everyone thinks
winning championships is peaches and
creams it's not
you're going to have these disputes
you're going to have these arguments
and a lot of times it's not the leader
you know the teams that i played for of
course i
was i was an arguer but brian shaw rick
fox would say some big shot bob uh to
say something
draymond you know he's not the best
player until no disrespect but
he's the guy that's always vocal he's
the heart and soul of the team
so you know sometimes you know these
things are good but you know the media
like they want to play like it's a
problem
having a heated discussion is never a
problem like you know people ask me all
the time you know chuck i have his skirt
but it's not a problem
it's all about respect so as long as you
got the respect thing there you can say
what you want to say you know
sometimes you know you have to call a
guy out sometime a guy has to call you
out
for you to you know recognize so i know
what that's about because
i got four championships and it was
never easy and it was never hey ernie
how's it how's your wife
it was never that it was you know going
back and forth he said something
i say something i don't like you today
whatever whatever but as long as the
respect is there
none of that stuff yeah and etiquette is
different ernie last thing i'll put it
and put a ball in it the etiquette is
different in an nba or nfl
or sports locker room than the etiquette
is at tnt
tara august who's back there who our
boss said she came out and said the
same things that a head coach would say
and say would say it hr would be down
here she'd be gone everybody here
it's a different environment so a head
coach is talking and a player is talking
in a much different manner
which has never been said to me in this
environment somebody tried to say
something like that in this environment
here
like it would be a whole different
animal
but in a locker room environment you
look at it differently and you're also
taking it in differently
but you're reporting it as you're in a
hr environment
in terms of at your job at your at
usa today or espn it doesn't happen the
same way
it was really funny when i was watching
the last dance
and you know because we all get together
watch it and we're smoking and drinking
and watching it and we're like
smoking water drinking cigars
i don't know wait wait oh
the last dance taught me one thing going
back to when i first got to the nba
and they're like hey young fella
whatever happens in the locker room
stays in the locker room but the thing
that was funny about the last days
those guys hated each other uh you had
all these
different thing coaches and general
managers hating each other
and that team won six championships
i always tell people i said those dudes
won six championship and they hated each
other
can you imagine on the crappy nba teams
how much stuff be going on behind the
scenes
that's why you have to keep stuff in the
locker room i know but the reality is
though i think
winning teams argue way more than losing
teams because losing teams they bicker
so if i'm on a losing team i'm gonna
come to you ernie and say hey man
shaq ain't passing me the ball and he's
freezing me out and then you partner up
with me and now me and you looking at
shaq like he's crazy
a winning team is gonna say jason your
body language was terrible in the first
quarter
because that's what i saw when i was
watching the game their offenses on the
run they're up a couple points
and he's not touching the ball and he's
dropping his shoulders but you're the
best player on the team
so yes i'm going to say something about
that winning teams will always argue
more than losing teams and
in fact you know the media can love
losing teams if they want if they don't
want any argument
and those teams will just lose and
that's that we are going to take a break
here on
inside the nba it's presented by kia um
[Laughter]
y'all tell tim cook i closed my rings
today i hope he's oh very good
oh what rings i don't even know what
they mean don't send things back
you need to get your apple watch you
need some activity
my personal friend tim cook all right
well you better call her i'll
i'll crush him i'll get you back to the
hotel all your stuff will be cut off
it's more than just sweeping there
smoking chuck
pookie